their nonsensical games are no longer
working so some of you may have seen
this over the last couple days the new
york times the failing somebody there
was an orange man who used to call it
the failing new york times he was right
about a lot of stuff it turns out uh the
failing new york times all they've got
left are lies and hit pieces so they ran
this
just this bananas hit piece on tucker
carlson just really just ridiculous
absolutely ridiculous hit piece and the
thing is it doesn't convince anyone yes
they've got their little sliver of blain
brainwashed blue npc people that read it
and think that tucker carlson's a nazi
but everyone else just mocks the [ __ ]
out of it and they're actually aiding
and abetting in their own destruction
it's quite beautiful but tucker's doing
the right thing doing the right thing in
the post-woke world which is that you
mock them you fight back and you
continue to do good work tucker carlson
this has got to be the 10th or 27th or
217th story just like this the new york
times has run and all of them are pretty
much identical racist racist racist
the latest version of the story is being
written by a kid called nick confessore
confessory seems a little more
self-important than most of them but
essentially he's the same as the last
guy and the guy before him because on
some level all these guys are the same
they're obedient little establishment
defenders who will say anything to
please their bosses they're suck-ups
brown nosers lick spittles
not people you'd want to have dinner
with anyway the new york times is
calling us racist again and we're still
in the air which shows you how well it
works
but you've got to wonder
why do they keep doing this
if you wanted to criticize this show
there are plenty of things you could say
we've got a ton of supposedly
controversial opinions on a million
different topics we talk about them
every night
big finance is wrecking america
marijuana actually isn't medicine
russiagate is totally idiotic and so is
the war it's now causing feminism is a
corporate lie marriage makes you happy
so does raising your own children and so
on even think ufos are real
so in some ways by the standards of the
new york times were pretty far out but
they never mention any of that
and the funny thing is the one thing we
do not have exotic opinions on is race
our view of race is really simple we
believe martin luther king
we don't think your skin color is the
most important thing about you we think
all people were created by god and
should therefore be judged by what they
do
not by how they look
okay so new york times runs this piece
uh tucker does the right thing which is
calmly uh fight back but then he did
this on twitter which this really is it
shows you where the shift is occurring
he just had someone take a picture of
him probably his wife at home with that
[ __ ] eating grin holding the new york
times which he should be wiping his ass
with
the front page hit piece on him and that
is where we are at this is how you win
you have better ideas you calmly explain
yourself and you mock these freaks and
then you build a better world that's
what you got to do